todo
[Música]
hola hoy en science click los agujeros
negros
el espacio-tiempo en el que vivimos se
puede concebir como una cuadrícula
todo objeto con masa distorsiona el
espacio-tiempo formando a su alrededor
un pozo gravitatorio
si otro objeto está cerca se verá
atraído y caerá en espiral dentro del
pozo gravitatorio como una canica en un
tazón cuanto mayor sea la masa el objeto
más fuerte será la atracción y más
rápido deberá actuar el objeto atraído
para escapar de la atracción
gravitatoria
si la masa del objeto se vuelve
excesivamente grande sin que el objeto
aumente de tamaño
el pozo gravitatorio creado será tan
grande que la velocidad necesaria para
escapar de él sería mayor que la
velocidad de la luz
como nada puede moverse más rápido que
la velocidad de la luz nada podrá
escapar de esta atracción
incluso la luz si se acerca demasiado
será atrapada
[Música]
esto es un agujero negro
en su núcleo un agujero negro contiene
una singularidad gravitacional un punto
en el espacio en el que la curvatura del
espacio-tiempo se vuelve infinita
cuanto más nos alejemos de esta
singularidad más débiles resultará la
atracción gravitatoria
una vez que alcancemos un límite
conocido como el horizonte de sucesos la
atracción gravitatoria se vuelve lo
suficientemente débil como para que la
luz que pase por allí pueda escapar del
agujero negro
así todas las entidades que se
encuentren fuera el horizonte pueden
aspirar a escapar del agujero negro pero
en cuanto un objeto se adentre en el
horizonte estará destinado a caer en él
sin posibilidad de regresar
como los agujeros negros atrapan todo
haz de luz que se acerque demasiado los
consideramos negros y por lo tanto no se
pueden ver de forma directa sin embargo
se pueden detectar indirectamente en
primer lugar su presencia revelada por
su fuerte influencia gravitatoria al ser
capaces de desviar la luz los agujeros
negros se comportan como lentes
gravitacionales que modifican la
trayectoria de los rayos de luz
procedentes de astros lejanos creando
así un espejismo gravitacional
como tienen una gran influencia a
distancia los agujeros negros también
pueden identificarse observando las
trayectorias de estrellas próximas
por último aunque los agujeros negros no
emiten ningún tipo de radiación por sí
mismos si lo hacen de forma indirecta
así alrededor de ciertos agujeros negros
la materia que los rodea se ve atraída y
forma un disco que gira alrededor de la
singularidad este disco al girar a gran
velocidad se calentará y emitirá rayos x
y gamma que son relativamente fáciles de
detectar
en el universo existen agujeros negros
de todo tipo de tamaño los más pequeños
conocidos como agujeros negros estelares
son causados por el colapso de estrellas
masivas
con un diámetro de unos pocos kilómetros
tienen una masa mucho mayor que la de
nuestro sol
los agujeros negros más grandes se
encuentran en el centro de las galaxias
estos agujeros negros supermasivos son
enormes y alcanzan varios miles de
millones de kilómetros de diámetro
finalmente aunque los agujeros negros no
pueden emitir radiación complejos
efectos cuánticos provocan la lenta
evaporación de cada agujero negro
emitiendo un cierto tipo de radiación
única que llamamos la radiación de
hawking
cuanto más grande sea un agujero negro
más tiempo tardará en evaporarse
[Música]
por ello en el caso de los agujeros
negros comunes esta evaporación es
extremadamente lenta y se extiende a lo
largo de miles de millones de años por
lo que tiene poca relevancia para
nosotros sin embargo es posible que
existan agujeros negros microscópicos
que podrían haberse formado tras el big
buck para estos agujeros negros
primordiales el proceso de evaporación
sería muy significativo y conduciría a
su desaparición casi instantánea
los agujeros negros son objetos de gran
complejidad cargados de misterio y que
siguen alimentando la imaginación de los
científicos han dado lugar a muchas
preguntas e hipótesis como la
posibilidad de que existan atajos que
nos permitan viajar a través del
espacio-tiempo los agujeros de gusano
[Música]